bienvenue et bienvenue à tous dans cette
émission spéciale qui sera entièrement
consacré à tout ce qui s'est passé
depuis cette terrible fusillade qui a eu
lieu mercredi à paris
l'attentât le plus meurtrier depuis une
cinquantaine d'années qu'ils aient lieu
et vous savez où sont morts douze
personnes dont les dessinateurs les plus
célèbres de charlie hebdo
alors naturellement parce que nous
sommes tous ceux bouleversé par la
violence la barbarie de cette fusillade
de cette attaque qui n'a encore
peut-être difficile de mesurer
exactement l'importance réelle de ces
événements les conséquences qu'ils
auront sur notre vie sur la société dans
laquelle nous vivons et sur les réponses
que nous devons y apporter
nous avons le sentiment peut-être qu'en
s'attaquant à ceux qui défendent est à
la fois la liberté l'intelligence et et
l'humour des terroristes sont d'une
certaine façon attaqué à nos valeurs
peut-être aussi à notre civilisation est
que à notre raison d'être et que tout
cela constitue peut-être une déclaration
de guerre qui nous a été faite qui a été
fait à ce que la nouvelle heure à notre
civilisation alors comment répondre à
ces événements sont in isolé howey
secours mais au début de quelque chose
de plus grave c'est à ces questions que
nous allons tenter de répondre pendant
cette émission avec florence mercadé
avocate
ça va ça peut aller est ce que c'est
vrai qu'on a tous un peu le moral de
relais dont les chaussures voilà c'est
depuis mercredi on n'est pas bien on
n'est pas bien mais sinon ça va merci
avec jean charles lajoie dix éditeurs
bonjour bonjour et jean-luc paddec
et syndicalistes évidemment alors nous
serons rejoints tout à l'heure par
michel doji que le maire de montigny le
bretonneux et que c'est le président de
la casse qui parce que c'était
intéressant aussi d'avoir le son
sentiment sur ces événements et sur les
conséquences qu'ils peuvent avoir même
sur le sur ce territoire même mais
d'abord peut-être première question que
je vous pose est quand vous avez appris
évidemment c'est cette terrible
fusillade de cet attentat quel a été
votre premier sentiment comme ça lance
alors j'ai appris j'ai appris cette
nouvelle j'étais au bureau comme pas mal
de gens
j'ai eu un peu de mal un peu de mal à y
croire parce que c'est tellement
tellement inconcevable que
voilà les inattendus même si le dernier
dessin de charme était quand même plus
que prémonitoire qui était quand même
absolument incroyable d'attentats voilà
il ya pas il n'y a pas eu encore entre
l'attentât
voilà exactement donc c'est d'autant
plus troublant
oui bon j'étais bouleversée comme tout
le monde ait le sentiment c'est un
sentiment d'un sentiment de révolte un
sentiment de de violence clairement et
puis après il faut un peu s'apaiser un
peu réfléchir posez les données du
problème est effectivement doit tout ce
qui maintenant les choses bougent
beaucoup puisqu'il ya un nouveau une
prise d'otages à vincennes voilà on
enregistre des missions nous sommes
vendredi après midi on les orgies dans
les conditions du direct mais il est
enregistré
donc voilà pour l'instant il ya deux
prises d'otages on ne sait pas encore
comment tout ça va se terminer
exactement là donc toutes les solutions
c'est vrai qu'on remue plein plein de
choses sur la façon dont on vit la
société qu'on a créé les messages que
l'on passé ce qu'on reprend retour
aujourd'hui et ce qu'on a laissé
s'installer dans notre pays donc il ya
plein de choses que auquel il va falloir
penser c'est peut-être un peu tôt parce
que je crois que tout le monde est
tellement blessée et
et très atteints dans la famille
certaines blessures d'humiliations
moi je ressens pas de l'humiliation je
ressens une très forte blessures et une
peine une peine infinie donc et sur les
solutions qui va falloir apporter le
savoir après le premier sur mon premier
sentiment saronni mais ben moi c'était
des c'était delà de la crédulité d'abord
puis plus de la colère parce que pu bien
évidemment de l'émotion parce qu on en
connaissait beaucoup de tous ces
dessinateurs qu on aime bien qu'on
connaissait personnellement plus parmi
les blessés comme d'autres donnent donc
ça ajoute au côté terrible après c'est
une immense colère parce que
contrairement à ce que ce que disait
florence et c'est pas si inattendue que
ça et ça fait des années que con qu'on
dit rien et que attentats après
attentats ont dit comme si c'était pas
grave parce qu'on veut fâcher personne
en fait donc donc moi je suis en colère
voilà je suis entré dans l'hyper et
c'est extrêmement grave
moi j'avais 15 ans 68 et pendant ses
jeunes années j'étais comme tout le
monde un peu révolutionnaire c'est
normal surtout maintenant syndicaliste
continue en fait et j'étais un fan
d'hara kiri est un inconditionnel du
professeur choron et vous savez hara
kiri a été interdite à taguer à la
lavande et regorge a été consacrée à
bâle iii lequel mort est un mort et
d'ailleurs vous savez que charlie c'est
finalement le diminutif de charles et
donc charlie hebdo a pris la suite
d'hara kiri
les dessinateurs qui ont été abattus
mercredi était pour moi les
représentants de ce qu'est la france
de l'humour parfois un peu de
grossièretés nous sommes faut pas se
cacher de la politique de la dérision du
cul des grandes bouffes et je crois que
là la cible de ces deux individus
probablement était organisée et je crois
qu'ils ont effectivement là atteint les
français au plus profond de ce qu'ils
sont en réalité ça je disais que c'était
ce que je voulais dire quand est excédé
nos valeurs et peut-être notre
civilisation a crié papa voilà c'est
terrible c'est extrêmement dangereux
parce que la suite hélas on la voit
aujourd'hui avec les autres informations
et il faut vite vite que nous trouvions
des réponses à cette barbarie j'en ai
d'ailleurs parlé dans cette émission je
vous rappelle cette phrase de voltaire
que j'adore que je cite toujours qui
enrichit son esprit pour n'oublie son
coeur on s'aperçoit que d'entretenir
l'ignorance finalement promeut la bêtise
et que la bêtise amène à la barbarie il
faut que nous soyons tous attentifs à
cela des démarches shanghai je crois de
demain dimanche royal le plus nombreux
possible au regard des barbares la
démence démarche durant lieu justement
parce que c'est des années déjà aussi
une polémique sur qui doivent y
participer est ce que tout le monde doit
y aller
est ce que ce sont les partis qui
veulent organiser c'est une question
vous posera peut-être michèle losier
tout à l'heure on a beaucoup parlé fait
la comparaison avec le 11 septembre
il y aura alors probablement un avant et
un après 7 janvier b
est ce que cette comparaison avec le 11
septembre vous semble long septembre
2001 et les twin towers
est ce que ça vous semble une
comparaison qui vaut d'être fait ou pas
sur le côté dévastateur que ça peut
avoir dans la société sûrement après je
pense que les américains n'avaient
jamais nier les problèmes comme nous on
les a niés depuis le début donc l'énorme
différence et pour ses protégés les
américains réponse est inattaquable mais
il était bien conscient qu'il y avait
des terroristes en puissance qu'il y
aurait des attaques peut-être pas sur
leur sol mais ils avisent appeler un
chat un chat
alors que nous depuis des années quelles
que soient les attentats quelles que
soient les coupables et même pas quelle
que soit on les connaît tous ceux
souvent on les arrête
certains se font descendre à chaque fois
on fait comme si c'était une sorte d'
épiphénomène et qui aurait pas de suite
qui avait pas d'avs ans qui avait pas
d'après la fermera le le
l'abruti qui est allé descendre des gens
en belgique dont le nom m'échappe mais
mouche je n'ai plus qu'à chaque fois on
dit robin c'est pas grave c'est fini oui
et mais non c'est pas fini et c'est
grave et là c'est pareil
alors je trouve ça très bien tout le
monde va se réunir dimanche il ya une
sorte de ne pas devoir sera de délire
mais de de compassion porté à son
paroxysme
et puis après on peut revenir là-dessus
s'arrêter un instant justement sur ce
c'est vrai que vous êtes vous avez
raison il ya une marche et c'est très
symbolique tout le monde allume des
bougies
on verra tout à l'heure un sujet ça
s'est passé l'autre d'autres soit à
plaisir par exemple mais ça s'est passé
un peu partout en france
est-ce qu'on n'est pas quand même par
rapport à un évènement qui est quand
même très très fort et très très
symbolique et très barbare pour
reprendre votre auto tam qui est tout à
fait juste est-ce qu'on n'est pas un peu
dans le compassionnel comme ça en
allumant des bougies en dise on est tous
frères on est tous ensemble
est ce que c'est la bonne réponse mais
dans le flot de commentaires et
d'intervention de tous ces dernières
heures
on entend effectivement beaucoup de
compassion on ira à la marche pour ceux
qui peuvent y aller évidemment mais il
ya une remarque que j'ai entendu de la
part d'un journaliste qui m'a frappé et
j'ai trouvé ça extrêmement intéressant
il disait la chose suivante si à
l'époque où sont sortis dans un journal
danois les fameuses caricatures de
mahomet l'ensemble des médias avait
repris ses caricatures il est probable
que les douze personnes qui ont été
assassinées dans les bureaux de charlie
hebdo seraient encore vivants
aujourd'hui je crois que nous avons
probablement fait preuve d'une certaine
lâcheté et nous continuons à faire
preuve de cette lâcheté
s'il ya une remarque à faire je crois
que l est nous devons nous nourrir de
plus de courage affronter les choses
telles qu'elles sont et surtout revêtent
je le dis très souvent la société sur
ses pieds vous savez il ya quelques
années il ya encore des endroits où on
peut laisser sa voiture la porte ouverte
personne ne va jamais imaginé venir
attaquer vont bien votre intimité or
aujourd'hui on se sent
je n'ai absolument sécurité et c'est
terrible parce que du coup cette société
qui déjà on l'a vu va dans le temps dans
le mur et qui est nourri de vide je
crois doit se réveille alors il est
possible qu'un événement de la nature de
celui qui s'est produit mercredi nous
réveille j'espère que ça nous réveille à
venir soit ça veut dire que nous devons
reprendre remettre au goût du jour ces
valeurs fondamentales qui nourrissent la
république je vous rappelle république
laïque
la religion est un problème intime qui
ne regardent que soi et dieu
or là on entend par là mais leurs
sérieuses à vérifier ça veut dire quoi
concrète des remparts concrètement
qu'est ce que ça veut dire aller au fond
déchets soit là aujourd'hui à un moment
donné il se trouve qu'on ne parle que de
religion
eh bien oui puisque c'est au nom de la
mairie ont donc la longue on s'est même
chose il ya bien d'autres phénomènes
dont la société a besoin aujourd'hui
notamment d'éducation et l'éducation est
parti en vrille
on le sait tous de référence aux valeurs
familiales pardon si ça choque c'est pas
une idée de droite ou gauche 1 mais la
famille est un des fondements de la
société depuis la nuit des temps et je
crois qu'il faut revenir à des valeurs
extrêmement simple qui font que chacun
d'entre nous doit se sentir en sécurité
chez soi dans son entreprise et dans sa
famille
oui mais les gens qui nous ont déclaré
la guerre c'est pas des petits voleurs
de voiture c'est des islamistes radicaux
donc il faut arrêter d'encore une fois
de dire on va à rééduquer les gens va
leur apprendre à lire il ya aucun
rapport avec des voitures volées aucun
il ya des gens il ya des gens qui ne
vous si tu parler d'insécurité je me
fous de la ccfl voiture volée et je me
fous de l'insécurité en ce moment
l'insécurité et les dus à des islamistes
radicaux qui sont un certain nombre qui
sont connus que les américains
connaissent les visiblement bio canope
les deux types étaient quand même
interdit de vol il avait interdiction
d'aller aux états unis et nous ils sont
en totale liberté ils se promènent
visiblement tu quel que soit le cas il
faut appeler un chat un chat
ces islamistes radicaux en déclarer la
guerre à la france
arrêtons de tourner autour du pot
arrêtons c'est quand je parle
d'insécurité je parle pas de vol de
voiture moi je parle de l'insécurité
dans laquelle nous avons mis cette
société c'est pas du tout les vols de
voitures
encore que on peut se demander la raison
pour laquelle tout le monde s'est réjoui
de voir que à la saint sylvestre et 12 %
de voitures brûlées en moi normalement
seulement en milieu de mille cent
sélections pour ceux qui se croient
importants c'est quand même quoi qu'on
puisse en penser de remettre une société
là où elle doit se situer avec de vraies
valeurs solides partager ce que des
monnaies qu'il faut qu'elle se défende
oui alors maintenant les deux individus
en question excusez moi tout le monde
dit oui ce sont des professionnels ils
savent manier une kalachnikov c'est
incontestable enfin quand même sur les
deux individus y en a qui perd sa
chaussure et l'autre qui oublie sa carte
d'identité dans la volaille c'est des
professionnels de la tuerie salanon ce
sont des abrutis tout simplement
j'ai écouté non et dans ses pages et une
explication parce que j'étais aussi
interloqué en disant mais comment
comment nos opérations aussi bien
préparé leur identité en fait comment
ils ont parfaitement bien géré le in ce
qu'ils appellent le in en termes de
lutte contre le terrorisme c'est à dire
qu'ils ont parfaitement géré la l'entrée
les assassinats et ce qui expliquait un
spécialiste du terrorisme et des
meurtres de façon générale c'est que
quand on a tué des gens on a une dose
d'adrénaline absolument invraisemblable
qui nous montrent au cerveau et c'est là
qu'on commence à faire des erreurs parce
qu'on est en sueur dose d'adrénaline
qu'on contrôle plus bien et c'est comme
ça que il fait pas attention il perd sa
carte d'identité il perd sa chaussure et
scellier a purement quelque chose de
physiologique et d'excitation extrême
qui fait qu'il ya des les erreurs sont
commises derrière et ils ont mal préparé
mais reste aux erreurs de temps sur eux
et ils ont mal préparé le out à ce que
on voit bien qu'ils ont bien préparé du
tout pour la sortie et j'espère tant
mieux et j'espère que ça se finira bien
c'est très intéressant l'idée de filmer
mais la carte d'identité ils l'ont perdu
après mais ils l'ont amené à vent donc
avait pas d'être ils sont quand même
paris le régime exécuté devant la presse
d'après ce que j'ai compris c'est parce
qu'ils sont arrivés dans une voiture
habillé carte d'identité permis de
conduire et qu'ensuite ils se sont
changés pour pour ensuite faire à ce
qu'ils ont à faire non puisqu'on parlait
de compassion justement il ya une soirée
à plaisir
on a allumé des bougies ou tout le monde
a proclamé je suis chargé je vous
propose qu'on ne regarde quelques images
et vous va recevoir toutes les d'après
michel laugier des bougies des pancartes
et toujours cette phrase devenue un
symbole je suis charlie 400 plaisir wa
étaient réunis hier soir en solidarité
avec les victimes de la fusillade
parmi eux des représentants de trois
communautés religieuses
en tant que citoyen c'est une valeur
fondamentale de un vibreur le respect
mutuel la liberté de conscience
nos condoléances envers toutes les
familles qui sont mises à l'épreuve
rudement avec aussi cette espérance
religieuse que nous sommes faits pour la
vie nous ça fait pour l'unité nous
sommes faits pour vivre ensemble et que
si justement nous sommes tous différents
c'est parce que eh bien quelque part
pour nous croyants quelqu'un l'a voulu
que nous soyons tous différents
non pas pour nous battre mais pour au
contraire nous enrichir mutuellement
je pense que d'abord en tant que citoyen
c'est très important c'est pour
venir dire à tout le monde que toute
personne douée d'intelligence et de
raison ne peut pas accepter un tel acte
c'est inacceptable et en tant que
musulmans nos valeurs nous le verset
coranique ne le rappelle ne le disent
une clairement sans aucune ambiguïté que
celui qui tue une âme c'est comme cela
tue l'humanité entière
une banderole réalisés par des jeunes
des applaudissements une minute de
silence et la marseillaise
un moment important pour le maire qui a
côtoyé de journaliste dessinateur cabu
et wolinski des personnes simples simple
mais d'une simplicité impressionnante et
avec une vraie profondeur culturelle est
une vraie analyse et en analyse et
analyse je dirais de culturel mais en
plus une humanité incroyable avec un
regard ça
d'autres manifestations sont prévues ce
week-end le prochain numéro de charlie
hebdo sortira mercredi 14 janvier il est
actuellement réalisée dans les locaux du
journal libération
pour que la flamme de la liberté
d'expression ne s'éteigne pas voilà de
retour donc bon n'ont pas fait nous
accueillons michèle louvier maire de
montigny le bretonneux et président de
la la casse qui michel logis vous allez
organiser demain une marche dans votre
ville c'est une marche à laquelle tout
le monde est convié tout le monde est
confiée savez quand on veut prouver sa
solidarité
il faut le rassemblement le plus large
possible donc mais aujourd'hui c'est
ouvert à toute la population à tous ceux
qui souhaitent se joindre à nous c'est
une marche sans prise de parole
uniquement
on va partir du centre ville de montigny
et nous allons nous diriger vers l'hôtel
de ville l'hôtel de ville qui est la
maison commune la maison de savoir tout
le monde sait le vraiment de symboles et
on terminera là tout est bon c'est pour
marquer un petit peu cette solidarité
que l'on doit voir parce que si beaucoup
vont aller sur paris sur parions sera
noyée par rapport aux autres je crois
qu'il faut que ce soit aussi visible de
la part de nos habitants il regagne
volonté aussi des habitants à 2
sa ville dans sa besace que de
participer aussi enfin voilà une montre
et ne montrait aussi d'une participante
et j'ai ce métier que la ville soit
associé jeudi midi donc j'ai fait au
sein de l'hôtel de ville aussi avec tout
mon personnel et quelques président de
l'association qui nous ont rejoints j'ai
souhaité aussi avoir cette minute de
silence
et donc j'ai vu que beaucoup de
personnes avaient répondu à notre appel
de manière instantanée puisqu'on a
organisé ça en toute vitesse donc là je
comprends un peu plus de temps pour
avoir de manifestations avec une ampleur
plus importante pour que tout le monde
comprenne bien les choses et qui est
cette solidarité
certes des moments comme ça qu'on doit
tendre la main aux autres est-ce que
vous irez manifester aussi dimanche
si je peux parce que je n'en prends du
temps à créer pas mal de charges sur le
principe tout et moi sur le principe
c'est instantané c'est tout à fait
normal que tout le monde soit solidaire
dans c'est dans ces moments là mais je
pense que ce qui est important aussi
c'est de le faire voir sur place qu'on
soit sur paris c'est une chose mais que
on exerce aussi cette possibilité de
pouvoir manifester sa solidarité par
rapport aux événements je crois que
c'est bien aussi que le fasse au niveau
d'une cobain
non je parlais de paris parce que c'est
vrai que les partis politiques se sont
un peu emparé de cette manifestation et
que voilà comment ces y avoir un débat
est-ce qu'il faut que les représentants
du front national soient ou non présent
dans cette manifestation
qu'est ce que vous en pensez peut-être
de re commencer par vous michèle losier
est ce que tout le monde doit venir à ce
que sur les parties qui doivent avoir la
main sur cette manifestation parce que
c'est au fond ce sont des individus qui
doivent manifester ce qu'a dit
d'ailleurs le président de la république
je marche aujourd'hui je préfère ce
soient des individus qui manifeste qui
viennent de là leur après chacun avec
son étiquette le mythique s'il en faut
mais avec jerry de tous tout simplement
ça c'est possible ça la possibilité que
ont tous les citoyennes aujourd'hui à
s'exprimer que l'on soit élu coup qu'on
ne le soit pas je crois que dans un
événement comme ça c'est de marquer vous
savez quand vous êtes des obsèques d'un
ami qui vous est proche vous regardez
pas qu'il ya autour
et l'on vous dira donc je crois que
c'est ça aussi la solidarité doit
s'exercer comme ça ce niveau là et je
trouve dommage que effectivement depuis
quelque temps au début on parlait de
grande solidarité de grands solidarité
au niveau du pays et puis d'un coup il
ya les débats politiques qui commencent
à aucune télévision temps des mois que
le front australie soit où qu'il soit
pas est ce que c'est le problème est ce
que c'est le problème aujourd'hui est
d'accord avec ça moi je pense que yi
on a créé un problème qui devrait pas
être et que chacun doit pouvoir
librement aller à cette manifestation et
qu'on doit être au delà des étiquettes à
tout le monde tout le monde je veux dire
ceux qui ne veulent pas du front
national et le front national au front
national et c'est en sortant bénéfices
quoi dans la couche nationale c'est ça
qui est regrettable
à l'intérieur de laquelle les chapelles
n'ont pas leur place
aucune chapelle nous sommes encore une
fois dans une république laïque
il va bien falloir à un moment donné que
nous rappelions cela à tout le monde
est ce que contient un attentat comme
celui qui avait eu lieu mercredi
quand on est maire d'une ville quel est
son premier sentiment est ce qu'on se
dit au fond balles et les types qui font
ça ils pour être venir de chez moi
exactement entendez savez si le ce qui
se passait vraiment comme ça qu'on se
rend compte que notre société est très
fragile et très fragile regardez ce qui
s'est passé donc à l'intérieur du
journal dans la rédaction
alors qu'ils étaient sous protection
policière alors imaginez un peu les
choses quand vous ne l'êtes pas tout
tout et tout est possible sauf que après
il faut savoir garder son sang froid et
les pieds sur terre aussi on peut pas
non plus dramatiser toutes les
situations parce que sinon on ne vit
plus on ne vit plus et savez le plan
vigipirate parce que tout de suite il ya
des parents qui téléphone alors le plan
vigipirate qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et
tout mais on était déjà que la seule
chose c'est que l'on voit bien les
limites d'ailleurs de cette protection
spir sauf que petit à petit vous savez
la vie continue et après si au départ on
est sur ses gardes on l'est de moins en
moins au fil du temps donc au départ le
plan vigipirate c'était qu'aucun parent
ne verrait devait rentrer dans une école
or aujourd'hui tous les parents entrent
dans l'école j'ai récupéré leurs enfants
normalement on aurait dû interdire le
stationnement de tout véhicule autour de
l'enceinte du nez d'une école regardez
montigny à 30 école si je commence à
empêcher que les véhicules se garent on
se gare plus d'un homme dans un génie
dont je pense que ça nous a pas empêché
de vivre jusqu'à présent sauf qu'il faut
toujours être sur ses gardes et il faut
toujours dans ces moments là à voir le
dialogue le plus constructif avec tout
le monde et ça c'est le rôle aussi
d'homère et moi je suis toujours en
train de discuter avec la population
avec les communautés avec eux tout le
monde parce que c'est la vie c'est la
paix sociale justement est-ce que je
pense à tout le monde mais est ce qu'une
des réponses justement à ces terroristes
on abordera peut-être les autres
réponses aussi à avoir mais c'est pas de
continuer de vivre comme avant parce que
est ce que l'un de leurs buts c'est pas
qu'on se taise qu'on se taire qu'on ait
peur que les gens se calfeutrent chez
eux qu'ils nous sortent plus qu'avec le
cinéma qui n'écoutent plus de chansons
est-ce que c'est face à leur but est ce
que la réponse est pas de continuer
aussi de vivre comme on le fait avec nos
valeurs et avec nos la vraie réponse ce
sont les journalistes de charlie qui
nous lourd à porter ça fait des années
qu'ils sont qu'ils ont déménagé et donc
ça fait et ça fait des années qu'ils ont
vécue comme ils l'ont toujours fait avec
leurs responsabilités avec leurs
provocations dont je pense que c'est ça
peut être le véritable ouais c'est de
continuer à vivre et d'être encore plus
fort
c'est ça que je crois que la vraie
réponse et ce n'est pas de se terrer ou
d'avoir peur je pense que c'est de
montrer et c'est d'avoir le buste bien
droit par rapport à toutes les
situations
d'accord avec ça moi je suis non mais on
ne peut bien évidemment qu'être d'accord
faut continuer à rire faut continuer à
publier des dessins iconoclaste et
mofaz des achats et donc ça s'est très
très bien
ça n'empêche pas que ne pas vivre dans
la peur c'est très bien mais il faut
aussi reconnaître quand il ya un quasi
état de guerre et qu'il ya des gens qui
déclare la guerre à faut arrêter de dire
ce n'est pas grave
et faisons comme si de rien n'était on
ne peut pas faire comme si de rien était
ça n'empêche pas de rire ça m'empêchera
pas d'aller au restaurant ça m'empêchera
pas d'être d'acheter charlie hebdo et de
soutenir tout toujours tous les
dessinateurs qui prennent qui
continueront à prendre des risques mais
arrêtons de dire qu'il n'ya pas c'est
pas une bière qui a déclaré c'est très
grave
voilà c'est vous pensez que ça déclarait
jusqu'à ce mot mais disons que la
situation qu'elle même est fragile
en france la situation est fragile et
d'ailleurs on le voit regarder eux
certains événements ont peuvent embraser
une ville très très vite
rappelez vous il ya quelques mois sur
trappe la ville sait tous que braz et
donc on voit bien ça tient à peu de
choses et en plus le problème c'est
qu'au n'est tributaire du comportement
de quelques individus seulement c'est ça
quand on est en guerre ait pu avoir des
pays en guerre mais on voit bien qu'à
quelques individus vous pouvez provoquer
ce concert et panique
est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on a une mesure à
ce que je posais peut-être les la
question aux services secrets aux
enquêteurs policiers mais est ce qu'on
sait à peu près quelle est la proportion
de 2 voilà d'islamistes radicaux de gens
qui sont prêts à passer au aux armes à
commettre des attentats est ce qu'on se
connaît cette proportion à ce que on
sait qu'elle est très très faible ou
est-ce qu'on a nos qu'une idée au fond
je pense que les services de police le
savent très bien de jeunes le savent
très bien leur après ça dépend de
beaucoup de choses ça dépend du
prosélytisme qui peut être fait ça
dépend des sites web eux ça peut donner
des lignes si on peut aussi profiter de
certaines situations pour aggraver
aggraver les cas savez c'est comme les
phénomènes sectaires on profite toujours
d'une personne qui en position de
faiblesse pour attirer dans ses filets
bien là c'est un petit peu la même chose
quand on a pas d'emploi lorsque d'un
peut rejeter ya intérêt aussi qui est
propice alors après le nombre exact vous
savez ça c'est très compliqué sauf que
on voit que de plus en plus il ya des
personnes qui manifestent leur religion
d'une autre façon que ce qu'elle pouvait
le faire jusqu'à près jusqu'à présent
c'est pas le nombre c'est le degré
d'influencé qu'ils ont fait ça parce que
nous voulons c'est que les médias disent
elles que centaines c'est plus radicaux
souvent de l'afflux en plein d'affluence
que le modéré et comme le disait
monsieur le président je pense que
l'influent ce qu'ils ont aujourd'hui est
de plus en plus importante
oui c'est vrai que cette influence
probable ont ils sont en train d'essayer
de l'awb l'augmenter l'accélérer par des
actes qui vont effrayer la population et
on sait très bien ce qui va se passer
derrière aux états unis après le 11
septembre
l'administration bush a pondu des lois
liberticides aux états unis dont on a
très peu entendu parler
d'ailleurs en france et en europe qui
sont des lois qui dure toujours aux
états unis les bafana mots surtout main
il y avait rien d'autre à propos de la
pression quoi que la presse est très
libre et c'était juste parfait du tout
elle est bien moins libre qu'elle est en
france c'est clair et tout le monde le
sait sauf qu'on en parle très peu en
france
ce qu'il faut craindre aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement la montée en puissance de
ses influences des extrémistes mais dans
les deux côtés d'ailleurs parce que
hélas ce qui va se passer c'est la
raison pour laquelle le mot guerre je le
trouve tout à fait juste il y à des
extrémistes dans les deux bords et
l'affrontement entre ces deux extrêmes
risquent fort de nuire à l'ensemble
d'une société qui ne demande pas ça
pardon je vois pas qui sont les
extrémistes d'un autre bord pour
l'instant je veux dire il ya deux
personnes qui ont buté 12 autres
personnes
voilà alors je vois encore une fois
pourquoi toujours essayer de trouver une
sorte d'excusé dira oui mais alors là le
ils sont très méchants mais il ya
d'autres méchants de l'autre côté
s'excusant l'héritière jean-luc
sélection ils sont homos guerre ce
qu'ils à ce moment les gens il ya deux
ans alors qu'il ya bien deux
belligérants
tant qu'ils y sont les autres les
islamistes radicaux d'un côté qui sont
les autres eh bien nous avons un certain
nombre de populations chez nous aussi
qui sont pas obligatoirement catholique
blanc et ventripotent mais il ya des
gens aujourd'hui qui sont tout à fait
prêts à en découdre ont commis des
attentats
les islamistes radicaux depuis dix ans
par exemple n'ont pas encore alors voilà
le dérapage jeune homme et ne confond
pas 1 tera page 12 personnes exécutées à
charlie hebdo c'est pas intérêt à aix on
peut pas du tout lui excusé ce qui s'est
passé à villefranche ce qui s'est passé
c'est pas c'est pas admissible non plus
un acte de guerre et puis de l'autre
côté il ya des choses qu'il faut
surveiller mais si on les surveille
effectivement aussi bien qu on a
surveillé les douze islamistes radicaux
on peut s'inquiéter
mais voilà arrêtons toujours de dire
attention c'est comme à chaque fois
qu'on parle de l'islam des oui mais les
catholiques sous l'inquisition
oui et alors une fois qu'on a dit ça on
n'a rien dit à 6-6 non non non on n'a
rien dit c'est ta vie que nous nous
avions mis des siècles à doubler dans la
voile religieux et que grâce à la loi de
1905 on a fait rentrer la séparation de
l'exil et à les choses sont nettement
améliorées
d'ailleurs sur le plan social il est
clair que cette séparation églises et
l'état a permis la progression de deux
sociétés
bon il est bien évident qu'aujourd'hui
il faut absolument revenir à la
république laïque et ne pas s'enfermer
dans un système où on ne parle que de
religion pour faire attention
maintenant la guerre des belligérants
très sincèrement il y en a du côté de
ces gens et il y en a aussi de l'autre
côté et j'espère j'espère que nous
serons suffisamment attentif et
intelligent pour ne pas permettre qu'il
y ait ces conflits
le démarrage de mercredi pose le
problème de façon dramatique
il n'aurait pas dû se produire je le dis
tout à l'heure si nous avions été
beaucoup plus solidaire lorsque les
dessin caricaturaux de mahomet sont
parus à l'époque dans un journal danois
peut-être que ces douze personnes
seraient toujours en vie aujourd'hui
voilà nous n'avons pas c'est l'audience
vous sentez comme ça comme par exemple
dans un certaine frange de la population
la volonté peut-être d'en découdre
ou est ce qu'il faut est ce qu'il faut
justement peut-être qu'elle pas calmé
les choses parce que il ya aussi
peut-être dans la volonté de ces
terroristes l'idée de pousser les autres
à bouée d'arrivée à 7 ce que ce que
samuel dumoulin appelé le choc des
civilisations je pense qu'il ya des
comportements qui irrite de plus en plus
je crois qu'il faut ni des comportements
qui rit faut dire les choses comme il
faut dire les choses et les
comportements qui irrite de plus en plus
par des tenues vestimentaires par
différentes choses sauf que
malheureusement on caricature vite
aussi permettez moi de faire cette 7e
que cette comparaison c'est à dire que
c'est vraiment leur sort de quelques
individus vous savez c'est ça aussi moi
il faut pas que on est un amalgame e
complet avec certaines religions
certaines populations
il ya aujourd'hui effectivement des
personnes qui sont dans la provocation
et qui irrite et qui irrite une autre
partie de la population et c'est vrai
que nous avons tous là dedans or la joue
et nous les élus les premiers débrayages
moi j'essaie dans ma vie le d'être au
contact des ongs et des autres de créer
de créer des lieux de rencontres de
parler de essayer d'avoir des
conseillers d'obtenir des comportements
qui soit l'auteur de ce que nous
attendons de tous les citoyens
parce que lorsque d'habiter dans une
ville au nez le citoyen d'une ville
quelle que soit sa nationalité quelle
que soit sa religion et dont c'est tout
ce travail qui est fait qui est long qui
prend beaucoup de temps mais en tout cas
moi je suis pour le dialogue entre entre
tout le monde mais encore faut-il aussi
après que l'on soit aidé nous avons des
lois en france au conflit qu'elles
soient appliquées
c'est ça aussi le vrai problème
aujourd'hui c'est que la loi n'est pas
forcément bien appliquée alors à
c'est-à-dire après semaine le pouvoir
par exemple on m'écoute et aux jo
aujourd'hui vous savez avant que mes
jeux
je sais pas par rapport aux endroits qui
se sont prononcés je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les personnes et qui sont
en garde à vue qui sont déférés au
parquet ressorte aussitôt quel que soit
le niveau
quel que soit le niveau de l'acte qu'ils
ont copie parce que aujourd'hui il ya
des avocats qui sont présents un témoin
je me demande ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui
pour aller un petit peu plus loin quand
je vois un élan aux relations interpellé
et qui sont relâchés très vite il ya
c'est pas le problème au niveau de la de
la police la police fait ce qu'elle peut
avec ses moyens et la justice aussi avec
ses moyens
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il manque il manque
forcément des moyens pour exercer une
vraie police en france et pour exercie
de vraie justice en france pendant suis
tout à fait de votre avis mais là on
connaît on a vite oublié les beaux
esprits qui avant mercredi était en
train de dire tous ces gens qui
reviennent du djihad des reviennent en
france et c'est terrible parce qu'on
menace de les emprisonner
il ne faut pas les emprisonner il faut
les épaules leur proposer des stages
c'est on a entendu ça des beaux esprits
et proposons des stages ou mais qui
reviennent du jihad
mais le stage y ont voient qu'on voit
comment ils s'en servent c'est ça qui a
été fabuleux dont il ya un véritable
problème bien mérité cette fois servi
mais parce qu'on est dans un état de
droit avec des lois est quelqu'un qui
revient du djihad s'il est gentiment
chez lui et qu'il ne fait rien il n'y a
pas de mails compromettants ou de sms
compromettants ou de conversations
téléphoniques permettant de penser qu'il
y aurait un début 2 parce que la loi
permet au café voilà mais la loi quand
on vient du djihad puisque c'est une
association terroriste à l'état on
comprend pas bien c'est pourquoi on les
laisse pas partir on ne les empêche pas
de revenir plus tôt que le faire le
contraire au manque de moyens notamment
en matière pénitentiaire parce qu'il ya
quand même beaucoup de gens marginaux
qui sont envoyés en détention est un des
frères d'ailleurs à passer trois en
détention mais se serait radicalisé en
détention et il ya des surveillants de
prison qui
raconter qu'en fait il ya des groupes
qui se créent en prison avec avec un
leader qui dit on aux surveillants de
prison ne vous inquiétez pas je contrôle
ce qu'on s'occupe d'eux oui ils seront
tranquilles
il n'y aura pas d'évasion il n'y aura
pas de de violences et on s'occupe d'eux
et l'aider et les routes se dire qu'il
ya une surpopulation rapporte ce fait
cette gestion interne par des groupes
non c'est ça va devenir derrière et ça
rend con mais ça arrange tout le monde
ce des surveillants de prison sont pas
assez sont pas suffisamment nombreux ce
soir a peur donc ça les arrange mais
pendant ce temps là le groupe ils se
constituent ils sont bien lavé le
cerveau et on voit ce que ça donne
derrière et c'est également un problème
de moyens mais on retombe toujours sur
la même problématique
ça les problèmes de moyens niveau de la
police au niveau de la justice au niveau
de la de la pénitentiaire sur tous ses
budgets la falloir faire des choix
politiques si on a envie de trouver
aussi des solutions parce que ces balles
soit affaire c'est que l'homme politique
que je pars il est dans l'éducation
parce que bon moi j'étais là bas loin à
non mais on va vous êtes sûrs comme un
droit mais moi je travaille plus pour
moi moi c'est ce 61 ans est bon on fait
ma vie voilà j'ai des enfants des petits
enfants et je travaille pour eux ce que
je fais là avec vous aujourd'hui c'est
pour mes petits-enfants pape ombre je
m'aperçois de quoi on a supprimé les
cours d'éducation civique
on a supprimé les cours d'histoire et
bien sûr que la nsa va pas les faire
ressusciter non plus mais par contre
projetons nous dans l'avenir si nous ne
faisons pas tout ce qu'il y a lieu de
faire pour que nos enfants sont mieux
éduqués aujourd'hui eh bien vous en
ferez des ignorants imbéciles demain est
donc là ce que disait jean charles
risque malheureusement de se dégrader
très sérieusement et là on va est vrai
tant elle est dans une vraie guerre et
ça il faut habiter sa est donc là je me
tourne vers l'homme politique c'est lui
qui prend les décisions avec ses amis
quel que soit d'ailleurs sa couleur
remettons au goût du jour dans les dans
les écoles l'éducation civique
les cours d'histoire refaisons un peu
les choses pour que lève les valeurs de
la république laïque soit mieux la
difficulté c'est que la valeur
aujourd'hui on est sur des valeurs de
consommation consommation argent cuba il
faudrait alors
je vais encore pire quand maniable comme
une question michel logis en tant que
maire et président de la communauté
d'agglomération est ce que vous pensez à
vous dites vous disiez tout à l'heure
voilà c'était des individus comme ça est
un peu et par les scouts penser que ce
sont des actes isolés est ce que vous ne
craignez pas une contamination aux
banlieues aux banlieues sensibles aux
lieux sensibles notamment de notamment
qui sont dans l'agglomération bien sûr
que nous craignons tous
vous savez chaque fois qu'il se produit
d'événements vous voyez bien que ça
donne des idées à d'autres s'adonnaient
temps réel
donc là il faut être encore beaucoup
plus vigilant vigilant je veux dire
c'est c'est grâce à la connaissance ou
là moi je ne suis qu'un élu local c'est
pas moi qui vais faire la réforme
je déjeune temps mais je n'ai aucun
pouvoir législatif voilà ce que je veux
dire je peux prendre des décisions au
niveau local mais sur l'éducation cetera
ce serait des lois qui devraient être
pris par des parlementaires au juge je
ne suis pas parlementaire et moi je
j'essaie de m'impliquer au niveau local
et au niveau finalement dans la dans la
relation directe avec les individus et
c'est vrai ce que ce que vous avez dit
chercheur luxe et qu' il ya aujourd'hui
une société qui n'est plus celle que
nous avons connue quand on est en jeu
avec des règles des règles de vie
aujourd'hui on est dans une société de
consommation où on essayait de niveler
tous les niveaux aujourd'hui bien tout
et voilà les valeurs bouleversé oui on a
dit blé et tous les tous les tous les
niveaux c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
enfin moi je
quand j'étais jeune j'avais du respect
pour certaines personnes et puis je
savais très bien que je pourrai pas me
payer ce que d'autres faisait bien
aujourd'hui tout le monde veut avoir
l'écran plat tout le monde va voir le dr
ipad tout le monde veut avoir le dr
iphone et quel que soit son niveau c'est
ça aussi c'est vrai que c'est un
problème de éducation mais tout ça ça
n'empechera pas que même si on trouve
des solutions
si minime soit elle ça sera déjà un
progrès mais ça n'a pas empêché quelques
indivise âmes se parlent à l'isaf à la
main pouvoir la mettre sur nos routes et
des actes innommables des ça
malheureusement cela on a vraiment du
mal à les voir et d'ailleurs moi ce qui
me surprend un peu c'est que ce soit les
services secrets américains qui nourrit
de son parti d'où le problème de moyens
que je parle plus inquiétant encore
parce que au-delà des énergumènes et
quel que soit le nombre de radicaux
islamistes
je vous conseille de regarder dans tous
les journaux et sur tous les sites les
témoignages accablants de professeurs
dans la france entière qui racontent
leur journée en arrivant en classe et en
disant voilà ce qui s'est passé on va
faire une minute de silence les des
classes entières qui disent mécontents
on s'en fout on en arrive c'est bien
décorée pas on l'est on avait on leur
avait dit de se calmer sont pas calmés
c'est pas grave c'est ça qui est grave
donc on n'est pas sur quelques personnes
c'est beaucoup plus grave que quelques
personnes ça y est le mal est très
étendue vous avez quelques personnes il
ya des jeunes qui réagissent comme ça
mais je pense que on a tous eu eu aussi
ce genre de réaction fait pas ce genre
de réaction a toujours eu des des côtes
et un peu contestataire lorsque l'un des
jeunes deux minutes y'a qu'il ya
quelques années
vous auriez une réaction comme ça vos
parents vous aurez peut-être foot une
claque mais voilà donc ça c'est sa
réaction était peut-être éventuellement
similaire encore que j'en doute mais les
sauf qu'il n'est pas
il faut se projeter bien sûr que là nous
sommes très inquiet pour les semaines à
venir où les mois à venir mais il faut
se projeter sur les années à venir pour
nos enfants nos petits-enfants et
permettez moi chers hommes politiques
que vous êtes michel même si vous êtes
un homme politique que vous dites être
locale enfin il ya autour de vous des
élus qui sont à l'assemblée au sénat
eh bien il faut travailler pour que ses
élus nous projette une société dans
l'avenir qui soit meilleure que celle
que nous avons aujourd'hui vous avez des
jeunes qui sont partis faire le djihad
oui jamais quelques heures
sauf que c'est des choses qu'il faut
savoir terre puisque c'est le travail
que nous faisons avec la police mais ils
jouent ligue arabe je vous le dirai pas
le nombre mais nous avons des jeunes
effectivement de la ville de montigny
qui sont repartis
les profils sont à peu près tous
identiques ouyahia mais un profil
particulier au south est très divers et
nous annonce est très divers rennais
visiblement certains cas on pouvait s'y
attendre d'autres pas du tout d'autres
pas du tout sauf que certains sont très
forts et d'autres sont très
influençables
mais ça c'est la vie et si vous avez des
filles qui sont partis pas du tout et là
c'est pas parce qu'on a c'est parti on
en sait un peu plus sur les frères
postulat qui sont donc les auteurs de la
tuerie de charlie hebdo
naturellement il ya eu la prison il y en
a qui est partie au yémen mais en même
temps ce n'était pas des gens c'est pas
totalement dépôt mais si vous avez vous
l impression qu ils ont été dépassés
je pense que pour en revenir aux
principes il pourrait promener sur son
petit garçon dans sa poussette tous les
jours parce que pourront venir laver les
les voisins sont comme toujours et à ses
fins comme toujours quand elle comptait
le contourne habite à côté d'un criminel
ont toujours effaré après en disant il
était si gentil et non mesdames
rappelez-vous ce père de famille qui a
disparu qui a tué ses quatre enfants sa
femme il était charmant mais c'est vrai
que je veux dire par là il n'ya pas au
fond il n'y a pas un profil particulier
qu'on pour le coup
sur laquelle on pourrait agir très tôt
en avance quoi vous savez même permettez
moi de faire une comparaison avec le
monde animal
quand vous enlevez un petit chiot trop
trop tôt de sa mère vous avez du mal à
les éduquer mais là je pense que c'est
pareil vous dites qu'ils aient un
comportement normal sauf qu'ils ont eu
une enfance difficile aussi de repères
donc heureusement tous les ans
heureusement que tournée en france
difficile du fait de supers sa version
mais non mais non mais je veux dire
c'est vrai que ce n'est pas le cas
heureusement pour toutes les situations
mais c'est vrai que quand on a un départ
un peu chaotique dans la vie on peut
aussi avoir quelques conséquences au
mini d'art est ce que quand on quand on
est responsable politique contre des
humains quand on présente des deux
communes et d'agglomération ça fait
partie d'eads et alors c'est pas un
événement que vous avez eues à gérer
directement 1 mais mais mais des
événements qui vous qui vous vous vous
questionnez le plus fin dans l'est dans
l'est dans les événements qui ont pu se
passer qui ont peu touché savez je crois
que face à situation déjà je pense qu'il
faut que les élus que nous sommes les
responsables doivent garder leur sang
froid pour donner cette vision là les
populations
j'ai été où savait très touchée très
ébranlé il ya quelques années avec le
drame d or ou l'associé deux enfants qui
ont été emportés par une coulée de neige
donc là oui là c'était fort c'était
c'était intense parce que en plus et s
nationalité que des enfants donc là
c'est vrai que ça m'a touché
personnellement et c'est quelque chose
que je garderai gravé dans toute ma vie
là on doit essayer de protéger protéger
sa population sa population par rapport
à des événements par rapport à
aujourd'hui à tout ce qui peut se passer
par rapport à des informations qui
peuvent filtrer les voilà à s'appeler de
tous les côtés puis surtout il faut
essayer de protéger tout ça donc c'est
pour ça que j'essaie bois d'avoir le
dialogue avec tout le monde
des plus jeunes jusqu'aux plus anciens
essayez toujours d'avoir ce côté modéré
parce que c'est pas dans l'excès quand
arrivera trop elle calme mais je crois
que c'est qu'elle met les choses
mais par contre après face à des
situations difficiles c'est aussi ça va
trancher ce savoir aussi dans des dans
des moments exprimé une position très
ferme mais avec beaucoup de dialogues et
c'est comme ça que vous arrivez à des à
des solutions savez aujourd'hui comme
disaient les pouvoirs publics en général
l'état moins de moyens conclusion
aujourd'hui on donne les responsabilités
année à des échelles de plus en plus
basses et aujourd'hui nous devons tous
supporters ont parlé tout à l'heure de
la de la police et dans une vigne vous
n'avez pas une police municipale ce
n'est pas d'élever des eaux surveillance
comment aujourd'hui pour être assumer et
assurer la sécurité des biens et des
personnes
si l'argent public communal ne
participait pas alors que normalement la
sécurité des biens des personnes et en
droit régalien c'est l'état qui nous le
doit tout ça est aujourd'hui regardez
vous de faire ces efforts là et ces
efforts aussi sont partagés avec les
associations heureusement qu'on a encore
un tissu associatif très fort et là il
faut penser aussi à ceux à tout ce
réseau avant que ce soit des solutions
sociales culturelles sportives
elle joue un rôle pédagogique et
éducatif et dorment et heureusement que
nous avons ces bénévoles là aujourd'hui
qu'ils s'impliquent tous les jours
puisque vous parlez de policiers
municipaux enfin les policiers sont des
cibles prioritaires un président d'eads
et des terroristes
est ce qu'il ya une sorte de crainte ou
de peur dans ce mot policiers la crainte
il ya toujours une crainte vous savez
lorsqu'un sondage dans la sécurité
des personnes et des biens on sait très
bien qu'il peut y avoir quelques risques
mais jusqu'à présent moi je n'ai pas été
confrontés et en plus puisque justement
on doit faire chacun des efforts pour
moi la police municipale est là pour de
la prévention non pas pour de la
répression
c'est pour ça que ma police municipale
départ mais d'accord donc c'est pour
bien rôle préventif de contact avec les
personnes pour essayer de trouver
quelque solution et des mines et
quelques mines suffisamment tôt pour
qu'elle n'explose pas alors vous allez
tu es journaliste mais c'est une
question je voudrais vous poser aux
arrêts les autres on a les scènes d'info
continue on sait absolument tout ce qui
se passe où enfin on croit savoir tout
ce qui se passe à chaque instant est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est une bonne
chose cette information comme ça qu'ils
nous aient jeté à la figure
les policiers sont les terroristes
d'arras on voit les politiques juin sa
peau s'ils sont dans les niveaux dans
l'aisne après c'est en seine et marne
on a toutes les caméras qui sont avec
eux est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
bonne chose ou pas une bonne chose est
ce qu'on ferait pas mieux un peu de
dates or un peu de savoir les choses
avant et dans et de et de raconter ce
qui se passait avant de les commenter
moi je pense que c'est une très bonne
chose là le danger que vous vous
signaler c'est que c'est à chacun d'être
capable de se détacher de ces images qui
sont souvent sans aucun intérêt c'est
clair que là ce matin je regardais on a
suivi pendant exactement une heure et
quart un convoi de deux
deux gardes républicains ou foot
gendarmes sur l'autoroute sous la pluie
qui se rendait à venir ce qu'on fait est
là les envoyés spéciaux ça va beaucoup
moins que les gens sont généralement
c'était ridicule je me souviens fort
dans la ferme et rap ans dans trente
heures on a eu un plan fixe de brm et
d'i télé sur une camionnette blanche et
donc c'est le rôle de ces télévisions
parce que s'il se passe quelque chose on
sait qu'on peut regarder mais ce qu'il
ya c'est que le pouvoir hypnotique de la
télévision est totalement démentiel
c'est à dire que je reconnais moi j'ai
un mal fou à me détacher de ces trucs on
regarde on est pris on est absorbé puis
andy va peut-être se passer quelque
chose alors on va vite se chercher un
verre d'eau un truc qui on revient pour
continuer à voir ses camions qui roulent
dans un bios de beaucaire la police joue
avec ça parce que est-ce que parfois on
indique des fausses pistes pour pour
mieux agir ce que est ce que c'est
vraiment les informations qui sont
données enfin enfin sûr c'est un peu à
betty son fameux je les regarde pas sauf
le soir quand je rentre il est 23h et
que j'ai besoin de regarder un peu
d'infos mais le journal je trouve ça
totalement creux il ya voilà y'a rien
n'y a pas de réflexion il n'y a pas de
vrai débat d'idées il ya de ces valeurs
et ces trucs en continu fins que ça
c'est abêtissant vois pas bien l'intérêt
on regarderait toutes les heures un
journal un peu construit avec un peu de
réflexion ce serait peut-être cela dit
j'ajoute juste un mot c'est quand même
grâce à ces chaînes et bfm pour ne pas
la nommer que j'ai découvert une
personnalité qui match nous époustoufler
qu'est jeannette bougrab avril est
carrément mais tue une femme épatante
saisissante qui s'est égaré s'était
exprimée de façon remarque alors qu'elle
vient de perdre son mari à façon sans
son compagnon c'était époustouflant de
justesse d'intelligent
après oui ils étaient affamés phase est
découvert l'a donc voilà de temps en
temps il ya quand même des grands
moments c'était c'était époustouflant
michel auger lancée là c'est tout à fait
différent c'était un témoignage apporté
dans le cadre créé la marque de ses
émissions continuent moi je trouve ça
très crus l'ancien leurs valises que
vous avez autour des bottes moi je pense
que ces chaînes ne font beaucoup de mal
parce que
on n'apprend rien lorsqu'en suite des
événements comme ça on vous passe en
permanence les mêmes images on vous fait
intervenir à l'antenne des envoyés
spéciaux et qui n'ont rien à dire rien à
dire et ne rien ne savent rien dans sa
veuve et ça me fait penser un peu aux
soirées électorales vous savez ou avant
a renoncé à peu près ce que tu veux dire
ensuite vient tout le monde à dire donc
avant on dit un peu tout et n'importe
quoi parce que ne connais pas les
résultats et puis une fois qu'on est là
il ya les résultats personne n'a perdu
tout le monde a gagné donc voilà non
mais sans aller jusque là ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui on passe en permanence
des choses et puis bien souvent on fait
passer à l'antenne des personnes et qui
disent n'importe quoi et les gens
prennent ça pour argent comptant
moi je me souviens je me souviens je
connais une radio rmc ce matin pour pas
la nommer absolument
c'était presque à mourir de rire
tellement parce qu'il y avait des gens
qui témoignait cabl y avait le type qui
allait livrer qui est inquiété sur le
truc d'autoroute
il y avait la bonne femme qui habitait
soi-disant en face alors on lisait mais
qu'est ce qui se passe à mehdi je sais
pas parce qu'à des arbres voit rien
écouté quand j'ai fait l'école de
journalisme on m'a toujours dit qu'il
fallait vérifier ces informations
will alors là c'est jour du mois niel
dirais c'est brut devienne rien
absolument balance n'importe quoi et
bien souvent en plus les autres les
autres
supports médiatiques télé radio
reprennent des fds selon le site de tell
télé sur le sud de tal radio et
finalement on véhicule de désinformation
qui sont et seront dé l'information est
devenue un bien de consommation comme un
autre et c'est ça le grand danger est
dans une société et florence avez raison
tout à l'heure qui est dans
l'immédiateté
là on veut du bonheur tout de suite on
veut la voiture tout de suite on veut
téléphone tout de suite on veut que la
formation tout de suite on est dans une
société où c'est l'immédiateté qui prime
et ça c'est extrêmement dangereux et
taylor que l'information devient bien de
consommation comme un autre
évidemment que l'on peut voir que des
conneries les est un vrai sujet parce
que vous êtes la politique n'est plus la
même
de ce gaz s'échappent darfour sait tous
qu'on voit les d'ailleurs l'homme
politique devient precia cet angle hélas
on vous met souvent dans des situations
mon chien michel qui sont raisonnables
on veut des réponses immédiatement des
résultats demain matin enfin c'est
intenable
oui c'est pas tout ça c'est ce qu'on
disait c'est aussi d'autres sociétés qui
a évolué avant il y avait un grand
respect pour le maire pour le directeur
d'école et pour le curé je parle d'un
village grippe ce que j'ai été élevé
dans un village
aujourd'hui le respecte aucun des trois
grands tours
respect merci merci merci merci à tous
les quatre voilà on parle de ces
événements alors qu'ils sont encore à
chaud puisque je rappelle que l'émission
est enregistrée vendredi après midi donc
que les prises d'otages sont en cours en
cours mais voilà ce qu'on pouvait un
petit peu dire sur ces événements qui
évidemment nous ont tous bouleversés
merci à tous
non